with us now is CBS News senior global
affairs contributor Ian Bremmer he is
president of the Eurasia group Ian good
morning corner there's so much to talk
about because the president agreed so
quickly to these sort of negotiations
but Margaret Brennan did a great job on
Face the Nation getting some details
from the CIA director first CIA director
said that the President of the United
States is taking the lead on this how
unprecedented is that well first of all
there's never been a meeting of any
leader around the world with Kim jong-un
and no American president has ever met
with a North Korean leader so what's so
appealing to this from trumps
perspective is he's first right and
that's a really big deal I think Trump
deserves credit for having pushed the
Chinese to toughen sanctions for having
made it clear to the North Koreans that
there might even be pre-emptive military
strikes that has facilitated North Korea
saying hey we're willing to actually
seize on any testing of nukes or
missiles until we meet and we're not
going to interfere why not set up a
number of conditions like the return of
the three Americans in North Korea
before deciding to a meeting not just
freeze your test freeze your whole
program I mean did he give some stuff
away of course of course he did and the
point is that getting to this point he
gets credit the process once the North
Koreans said hey we're willing to do
this stuff has been a bit small the the
Secretary of State had no idea and
literally had no idea that is that's
thoroughly unprecedented why explain to
people why this is important though in a
negotiation you need leverage so if the
president offers himself already in the
beginning of the negotiation he's
removing his ability to be used as
leverage as negotiations continue well I
mean he can always change his mind but
the fact is that it's harder right I
mean he's made a big give to the North
Koreans by saying I'm gonna legitimate
you I'm gonna meet he doesn't think he's
given anything but he doesn't know
anything about this policy like we we
know we've already seen it with tariffs
Trump's ability to make big statements
because he doesn't understand details of
the policy and then people have to walk
it back that actually implement is
overwhelming and on North Korea that's
dangerous did you point out he and no
other president has ever done this
before there must be a reason for that
if you could talk about that so huge
upside what's the downside the reason
why Obama Bush Clinton have
met with North Korean leaders is because
they understand that dealing with what
is already a nuclear power a rogue state
no information incredibly intractable
things can go really badly if you offer
a head of state meeting you make your
presidency about North Korea which is
you know that in Israel Palestine like
the hardest things to try to unwind
presidencies can go south on that sort
of issue and if you have a meeting with
Kim jong-un and it goes badly or the
meeting goes well and then they cheat
they don't actually go forward with what
they've promised you and there you had a
lot of their word that's right there's a
lot of egg on face and if Trump's
already said we can do this the easy way
or the hard way we're gonna we're gonna
hit these guys if they actually continue
with their program harder to back away
from that but if you're gonna use
military action or that's a part of your
thinking don't you have to show that you
tried everything possible in the
diplomatic front if one day it comes to
military action yes so that's what Trump
is doing well no but trying everything
possible does not mean start with a head
of state meeting trying everything
possible would mean getting your envoys
involved in both sides and the South
Koreans bringing this offer to trump
they were not suggesting hey go and meet
with him right away that they're
actually concerned that Japanese are
best allies who they thought that Trump
was doing a hard line which the Japanese
supporting suddenly the Japanese
completely blindsided by Trump accepting
a meeting you want to have your allies
on board that means the Japanese and
South Koreans you also want your allies
inside the administration on board and
Trump a good job getting to this point
and abysmal job because he's going it
alone you you need to have the people
around you that can help get to a better
place I hope that changes in the next 72
hours just quickly Kim jong-un has never
left North Korea where could this
meeting take place the easiest place for
a take place will be the peace house DMZ
right that and I suspect that's what's
going to happen I also suspect that
Putin's going to offer his services to
help align these two sides at some point
it'll be interesting to see how we react
to that so you're not thinking
mar-a-lago I think mar-a-lago was not on
the agenda memmer always good to have
you at the